what I did this week was I put a load of
Twitter to ask people what they wanted
to talk about as it happens one came
back and said strange living situations
now it really I was on I was on the
phone to you the other day right and I
haven't I deliberately haven't asked you
about this because I wanted to hear
first time on the podcast genuinely you
said to me the other night when you're
on the phone you having a bit of bother
with a bloke who you live with you have
a shared living situation and I could
hear him shouting in the background I
then run you a daily a new full of
wreaths you were go to the police
station about this or something like
that yeah so what tell us what's been
going on at home
so I originally that an caveat this with
the fact that it it make I'm not
culturally insensitive towards other
people or I live in a part of London
where it's predominantly a mixture of
like Caucasian guys and girls and I like
the Bangladeshi community of London they
all live around Brick Lane and you're
loving it and it's a nice area to live
because a there's some really good food
and B it's like not quite a nice family
quiet area no one read bothers anyone
and it's nice and if you know if you
want something you cannot get it well
yeah what do you mean by that you know
if you won't pull - no no like if you
want if you want like good food you can
just walk out it's on your doorstep
you know it's gang leader she community
admit good food well I mean just there's
a lot of good chefs in the area I'd it's
notoriously for anyway by the by so I
was looking for a new place and I'd go
in with the estate agent the estate
agent goes in lovely through the place
there are two young professionals living
in here you'll be absolutely fine I was
like I'd have to meet them it's alright
I've lived with a few strangers because
generally when you look around London
you're like oh I need to take this place
but earlier school boy era now I've
moved into places before before meeting
people I was fine and I you know I tend
out you know even the most situations
you barely ever come into contact with
them anyway so first day I mean you're
living with them you barely ever come at
the condo don't like you know you open
your door close your door you know that
day young professionals cause me it's
two other guys as far as I'm concerned
it's only the first day I moved into the
house
open my door and there he is standing
there as I described them I want to know
what he looks at I wanna know his age I
want to know everything he's like a
middle mid-30s he might bear on me so
sort of five five or five foot six five
foot seven her graying hair and he's a
lotion all abou he's American and he's
kind of his back American guy but quite
small and he has like a bit of an
American accent
but not quite rockin identify where it's
from Jenna says he's from Chicago and
says he doesn't like Barack Obama but
and I and I'm step I'm standing there
like okay we're not gonna get along
right and then but the thing was Donald
Trump is like coming up at the time so
he sort of says to me he's like do you
like he's trying we're trying to gauge
each other so we're standing there like
two guys in the hallway and he's like a
few things you need to know I'm no and I
was I'm I'm perfectly reasonable cuz I'm
not listen you know I might have my you
know I've got a best friend who
sometimes comes down to stay with me or
Lisa I've got a girlfriend she's gonna
be coming round to the flat like you
know we're just gonna be relaxing around
like any normal flat words like or you
know it's it's not cool if you bring
people someone you're not married to
into the house and I was like my few
issues might be we're gonna have a few
issues there make sense right anyone
what whole disease you're not married
no it's not Texan he's he's got like a
married he's got me in common in boy
yeah it's very similar to the her than
their and then he said I'll be bringing
gunmen who don't touch my cutlery damage
my [__] calorie and cut us and
don't speak to my wife and I was like
you know one of the [__] wife you
know what that saves me a conversation
but I don't want to have any like most
the time you're like I don't care anyway
were just we're just lick life yeah well
I wasn't ever gonna touch his wife you
come from a whole other world
all right no I almost slept your where's
boy I'm talking my first problem anyway
so the problem comes when just living
alongside someone else you if you want
to let's see it you've got blue balls
you haven't seen the missus oh no no no
I don't take now don't even bring up
I'll bring her on I said I don't care
I'm bringing my girlfriend back because
you should just be made welcome however
you want so you know my girlfriend's
more than welcome to come from my side
into the house
right not from his side all right the
first time I bring her back she goes to
use it goes to wash our hands because
we're about to eat dinner and I saw you
were about to I'm about to eat dinner
and she's in the bathroom and I'm
waiting in another room like cooking
dinner preparing stuff right and out of
nowhere all I hear is what the hell is
this
I've no out of no way right and right
now you're shaking the table to the
point right in the in the bathroom what
the hell is this right out of nowhere
and I my girl my girlfriend more than
that for herself so she's just like what
what is going on I came out in the hall
and he's there and he says to her he
says get out get out of this house
you're not on the leash you're not
allowed in and I was like well you're
like guests he's like no no one no one
sanction this I'm gonna go to the
landlord etc and I was like man no one's
saying shouldn't levels allowed a guest
hmm
listen man everyone's allowed a guess
cuz I take another people's accident and
my girlfriend's like obviously little
bit shaken up by the situation so he's
choking a hill you shout at her and
she's the funny thing is right she loves
get like she's more than capable of
giving back so she's like I'm I'm
allowed in this place what's your
problem
so we both stand there in the hall and
he says she could be anyone and I was
like she's not anyone I'm here I'm right
here my girls my girlfriend and not only
that but like if you walk into you know
you've seen my girlfriend she's you know
she's not a very threat like physically
not in person she's she's very slim yeah
like she's you know and he says yeah but
she could she could be anti-islamic oh
my [__] god
so is he is he obviously a Muslim he's
Muslim that really doesn't come into it
well that's why he's saying you know no
sex under my roof young boy yeah but
then do you own the place no thanks
that's what you think cuz I've been
having sex for meself for the last week
took it away anyway right loving it so
I'm bit you put this way you wouldn't
get along with him so he was like I want
to [__] up the cut note be honest so
what happened not because he's a Muslim
just cuz he's a wanker yeah because he
is a right so I'm trying to think the
first time that he ended up
so anyway I have a friend down and I and
he and I say I go to him and I say is my
best friend right and you know when you
live in one room I'm your best friend
who's one of my best friends I'm a best
friend from it being from childhood
comes down and when you have a guest to
say in London there's not very much
space so I'm a friend of coming I'm
sleeping the same night your space
anyway I'll sleep in the same bed
there's nothing weird about it you know
you know each other with it with it with
it you you can't no I cannot let this
quake are you way all right fine you
sleep in the same bed with your is this
a fella I'm assuming yeah yeah a man do
you do what do you top and tail do you
sighs I will be top and tail we're
absolutely fine sighs you ever seen more
command wise should yeah but I mean
teaspoon and all I know why would we why
would we spoon I'm a grown man like I
can't even fit in another but like
literally it's like a woman's name but
you know I mean yeah so I've got a
double bed what if I make a nice big
double bed so it may it's more than
reasonable for fitting to people in oh
so you share up spooning him in single
you share a bed together
yeah so we hear bed make a lot what you
will um make it my lowly let me know
because I don't think there's anything
weird about sharing a bed with your
friend I share beds Minh my family's all
about when this is happening are you
drunk
I was this oh but like what's it it
wouldn't matter if we were drunk crossed
over anyway nothing's gonna happen wigs
are sort of that strange aura tell me if
we went away you wouldn't you wouldn't
feel comfortable if you and I shared a
bit I wouldn't want to share a bed with
you yeah but if the situation arose it's
not like I'm gonna be like oh well to be
honest I was getting it tonight I've got
to be honest you would be on the floor
and I'd be at in the bed that's how it
would work I would always think of it
the other way around but fair enough and
or you'd be on the floor
I think I'm all the tougher no I'm not
you'd be lying on the floor I'd be lying
on a bed and never the twain shall meet
yes all right so carry on your mates
coming down having a birthday having a
big bash so we know I mentioned a
birthday um no no no so anyway we are
laying in bed about 1:00 a.m. and as we
it isn't like this gives that way to
Mossad is we're laying in bed my god
because I'm just don't you realize he
probably just think that's a good thing
here yeah so
he's angry that I have a man and so I'm
laying in bed and and what I wouldn't
both my friend and I have a bit of
passion for podcasts right so we loved
you whole podcast as we go to sleep we
play brock obama's audiobook just a [__]
this guy knows it perfectly quiet like
you know at night you can barely like
you know when i close my door you can
barely hear anything right and I've
tested it I've gone outside my room
played music this is the point I've come
to where I've gone outside my own
bedroom in my own house
played music in my room and check what
you can hear and it's the sort of thing
where it goes hmm
so you can't really hear anything out of
nowhere I hear very loud music right to
the point where I turn to my friend like
it's 1:00 a.m. in the morning we both
fight so oh good night yeah but it go to
sleep we're both talking ourselves in
right and there's no one UN doing that
and out of nowhere really loud music oh
got his music isn't it so I go and I
turn to my friend I tapped on the
shoulder I'm like all is actually really
good sometimes people have like wedding
parties in the neighborhood let's go we
look out the window and I'm like of
music's not coming from outside the
window it's behind us inside the flat
you're like a red cultural oh yeah so
you're like learning me they're all just
gonna be great you love it you love it
yeah it's a little say oh yeah yeah part
yeah
there's gonna be a festival it's gonna
be fun he's nice instead it's it's
coming from it oh you look you look at
me and you look together and you look
the return you go oh my god it's coming
from yeah so I like Italian food and you
live with your dog so he just goes Oscar
I'm going back to bed I can't bother
with this now I'm like okay there's a
little bit weird at this point right
because he he loves to plays music
around the house anyway but it'll only
play it when I play my music so today I
come to my music what kind of music is
he into out of interest I think I think
it's like prayer music alright so it's
definitely not so he's not listen to us
or Barry White no doggy's yeah so he's
not trying to woo me Matt's out on a
haircut so I opened the door and outside
my door is a chair that's clearly been
set down exactly outside the door with
what looks like a Nokia 3210 on
blasting music like and I'm not kidding
it's like I've never like I could set my
iphone down and it wouldn't be that
noisy it wouldn't be that loud you know
you play music at your iPhone it's like
that but imagine that 1:00 a.m.
piercing through the night right not a
that is in the fridge
not sorting the fridge but just taking
things out and then slamming them back
into the fridge and I say what are you
doing so legit like you can imagine me
fairly in crazy I'm what are you doing
and he's like what are you talking about
it's 1:00 a.m. what do you what do you
mean and I was like it's one em like
what are you doing why are you in the
hallway playing music and what are you
doing is I'm sorting the fridge I'm like
at 1:00 a.m. and the guys like yeah of
course as I course like you're his son
in line he's going to teach me lessons
in it's as if you're disappointing him
with your choice of lifestyle in a way
and he's having a footman meltdown I'm
not joking I'm not joking when I when I
told him and this is where it makes me
sound culturally insensitive but it's
not when I first told him that I am
having a friend to stay he said to me
this wouldn't happen in a country with
Islamic laws like you just wouldn't be
allowed to have another man stay in your
house and I was like well we're in
Britain was it I don't I don't quite
know what you're getting out of it that
really [__] me off when people come
like if I you know now you look now you
may begin some really culturalism
because I understand why someone but if
someone's got religious beliefs or
whatever then I'm more than opens that
like Mike within this 4 walls all you
can do whatever the [__] you want is not
yet but it's not him away so many phones
dance or whatever happened using ones I
don't think that's his aspiration in
life anyway he can cover himself in lame
green paint whatever he wants to do I
don't care so anyway he can do any weird
shitty ones she gets a little bit easier
than you yeah so can you listen man I'm
not sure that you will enjoy anything if
you wanna not your meat off yet all day
that's your you know what if I wanted to
I I would but I don't
all right good for you yeah good it's my
choice it's a choice of a heterosexual
lifestyle I love to leave all right so
we're then in the hallway and he's like
ah son you can't be doing this son and
I'm like
like gon go back to bed and he's like no
you go back to bed so we're now arguing
over stupid little things where you go
back in your room and I'm like man this
is stupid you go back in your room
ha ha ha so I'm I'm I I then go back in
my room and I'm angry my friends like
sorry I don't worry about it man we'll
just go to bed and don't worry and I've
got a big shoot next day or just holding
your hand at this point we're very
affectionate friends I'm not the feds
okay so the husband that has there is a
point in sight wait he there would be a
point where that if I knew this was
winding him up that much though cuz I I
can't help a piss-take I just can't
fight the Earl you know me so if I if
I'd be in that me I would have like put
my arm around you and I would have been
like hey just come back to bed - I'm not
I'm not joking I would I would have
deliberately cut it up Graham Norton
hundred bucks yeah
I'm not being the compass man ever just
a [__] with this guy this is what I was
thinking you know could we go down there
I couldn't stop me so I I thought you
know what
he's probably it's late at night he
would you know he's probably just having
a bad day or so let's just let it go all
right let it go
so my friends like yeah let it go don't
worry about is right so anyway I'm
trying to think of the first time that
there was a blow exchanged between the
two of us a blow yeah I I didn't know
what you mean by no no no but between
the guy that I live with and me right a
bull what you mean like it yeah no I
didn't I didn't I haven't hit anyone in
this but he he's like he's tried to
actually strike at me when was this I'm
trying to think the first time trying to
think the way around it the first time
there's been more than one time yeah
yeah
join us a club known and sort mote know
will gore oh no no no don't worry pal
yeah I definitely don't want you to
publicly suggest any of this stuff
alright because if you know because he
he isn't my friend I'll sort notice five
four five meet with all due respect
everyone five four five out there
there's no five-foot five man in this
world taking me on oh yeah yeah and now
I'm good for this guy so this guy then
what was just want to say Conor McGregor
do actually love them but disappointed
everyone keeps trying to eating them
trying to stir [__] up but I actually
don't wanna hurt you I just want to meet
you have a good time I just want to meet
them hub on the podcast okay clear a bit
of UFC on Xbox well so anyway to deal
the first time there is they forget the
point he ends up
because later this something happens I
can't quite remember what now but I've
got it ring that anyway something
happens and he sort of does he basically
comes at me and like digs me in the ribs
and like lands a punch lands a fairly
like hard punch there and I'm like you
know I've had enough this man like now
you've hit me you've taken that too far
cuz I I would have no problem having a
fight with someone but I don't I don't
want to do that I don't want it to have
to come back the Liverpool route to
teach him everything you phoned out
before you would you you know I've never
I've never exchanged a punch with anyone
but if someone comes at me then I'm
gonna defend myself so any the first
time he did that the code no he dug me
in the ribs and I just basically pushed
him away right and was like you've gone
too far like now you trying to
physically intimidate other people in
the flam going to the police
mistake he goes to the police as well
and tells them I've punched him oh my
god so I go to the police and the police
are interested obviously why I've saying
and they say do you want to press
charges this is where I make my first
mistake I didn't press because they went
it's your word against his what are you
gonna do it'll go to court daughter oh
now he does press charges so he doesn't
press charges right obviously isn't
perfect matches because he's like right
so I I go back and I say to the police
like look I just want to let you guys
know so if anything does happen
then I've got like a record of that
happening right and he then got he he
goes the police tells me exactly the
same and neither of his press charges I
say to hit I say to him and I say to the
police I'll give you a few days cool
down if you want to come and apologize
to me after that that's absolutely fine
in those few days he doesn't come
apologize doesn't say a word to me
starts doing little passive-aggressive
things around a religious one not the
more sort of this is where my prompt
spiritual is that he says to me he says
to me I'm I'm a I'm a religious man but
I'm not a forgiving person and I was
like probably missing the base of your
own breakfast what you preach anyway the
point is that I want the second time
it's 1:00 a.m. in the morning bang bang
bang pots and pans in the kitchen right
mm-hmm I go into the kitchen cook on
something like cause I don't know and I
go what do you do again like this what
do you do why doing this and he goes I'm
washing up can't you see and I'm like
it's 1:00 a.m.
will you listen to barackobama volume -
I was in my headphones listening
something and
so loud that I could hear through my
headphones this banging righty-o who
your headphones or audio that's a really
good point yes so anyway I I go out I go
in the kitchen he's like get out I'm
trying to wash up and I was like I'm not
going anywhere man this is my own flat
he goes if you don't get out I'll make
you get out and I was like well had like
to see this and I didn't realize this
guy a little bit of a push he like gets
low and like pushes me as hard as he can
out the room literally hitting the wall
that's the thing with religion comes
great power yeah but let's not let's not
mix it with religion let's make sure
look night so anyway I'm like man again
you've crossed another line a physical
line let's call the police
meet you you need to have someone come
around and tell you what they're you
rules stop telling him right you
could've caught at least I was one of
these days you're gonna not make it on
that phone and your [__] head is
going to be cut up he's gonna look just
what happened and I'm great without
someone to do the [__] podcast with
yeah I don't have to go get him on this
is what happens right I go to the piece
and please go okay come and wait for us
outside I'm waiting outside in
basketball shorts no hoodie for half an
hour for the police in which time he
goes out the house got somehow finds a
back route and walks back into the flat
in front of me as if I'm not even there
so I'm sitting there like this guy's
associ about this guy is just a mental
the police come round and they go is
obviously all very very silly YouTube
just had a bit of an exchange and
obviously you've hit him he's at you and
I'm like no one's here I've not hit
anyone and he's like well obviously he's
come and told us that you've hit him and
I was like well this up so he's all yeah
you hit me and I was like go ahead then
tell the police when his story changes
in front of the police and the police
still go well nothing to be done here I
understand they're like is there
something wrong with you is there
something wrong with you this love story
has just changed in front of you guys
about what whenever I hit him and you're
like well this all adds up we better be
off to be fair though there are a lot of
contradictions in religious texts so
it's probably silly he's probably not
even notice that he's doing it
don't lose his people off because
obviously religions very important some
people I want to value that all right
and I got you know and I'm obviously I
value other people to leave anyway this
comes to yet another head the other
night when I go into the kitchen when
again he's banging around at 1 a.m. and
listen man you're a hypocrite and a liar
you've lied to the police and you're a
hypocrite for saying that you want a
quiet life but you bang around at 1 a.m.
in the morning
he he basically just goes like I say to
me you can't be doing your washing up at
this time like a stupid go back to bed
or like do whatever it is and go back to
bed but don't keep me doing this and he
was like no I'll do whatever I want it's
my flap now I was like everyone's flat
it's really inconsiderate
to do the washing up one o'clock in the
morning so anyway I walk out the kitchen
and he slams the door in my face right
so I try to open the door again I'm like
listen if you start treating people like
this you're like you're gonna have to
leave and he's like no I'll get you out
the flat and I'm filming him this whole
town with my phone right mmm oh my god
totally you've got the footage in
furious although you can see it for no
no no I'm furious YouTube nutkum it
infuriates him that I'm filming him
because he's like fine two people can
film and I was like fine two could play
their game to play filming so please
stand there with his iPhone I'm standing
there with my iPhone we're standing
there in the hole
filming each other just doing nothing no
nothing and and I go is it true that you
lied to the police on camera and he an
off-camera he'll be like yeah yeah
whatever
on camera I go the point is you can't
reply on camera cause soon as you reply
on camera you know that I can go to the
police and go look he lied to you
any won't reply won't say a word why on
earth are you telling him you're
recording you need to get it on the song
it's very it's very obvious come on you
need you need to have it like lay there
by your side anyway knees talk police
and the police come oh god you've
nothing he comes the police and police
come over so I then I then go back into
my bedroom start to go to bed oh [__]
police at the front door please come in
I'm I'm obviously listening from begs I
can hear everything and I hear him go he
was Islamophobic the policeman goes well
that's a very serious hello allegation
what woman has he said which would me as
I'm a phobic and he said he called me a
hypocrite and from the policeman said
with all due respect us that's not his
lima phobia that is and I said she just
that could be that could be true and
he's like well he has told to me in the
police like okay what what what assault
did he do he said he tried to open the
door while I was in the room policeman
is like that's not so that's
embarrassing
thank said sir he filmed me again that's
not illegal easily he's allowed to film
you okay then well you're you're not
here for a reason so the policeman comes
in my room he goes listen man it's very
clear what's going on here
all you need to do is get out the flat
so I'm looking for another flat at the
moment so any people listening in the
London area I don't live with you if you
have ear room spare I don't know maybe a
little home with your mother you've got
a spare room
Lawrence you know I wouldn't mind
sharing Xbox things I'll be sharing Xbox
yeah share a mother yeah so yeah the
options are wide open wide quite a lot
of listeners under here aside yeah let's
get you home yeah let's find let's find
me remember Lawrence isn't just for
Christmas it's for life so if you do
take me and you will end up with you
know somebody's somebody needs walking
regularly etc edge what about moving in
with the girlfriend is that an option
yet yes in a few years now probably
should exactly yeah commit or get off
the pot absolutely so yeah yeah I've got
a story a lot less long-winded than that
one I do I feel like that was a series
of stories I stitched together it was
was it felt like [__] war and peace
God Almighty went on for a while my
story is when I had my first flat on my
own living on me on a block of flats and
I walked past the bottom and I see a
little old lady who was living there on
our own cars being about 60 some of the
late fifties sixties she looked a bit
all that cause she clearly her you know
had a hard life so I go up to her and
she's looking at you thinking the same
well she probably looked at me was
pretty terrified to be fed well I like
the when out there's an old woman there
I like to say oh hello just to let them
feel a bit safe you know that I'm not
gonna mug them and murder them or
whatever they're worried about anyway
she she offers a cup of tea I know she
lives on her own with our dogs and that
I felt a bit bad so I go alright then
I'll have a cup of coffee or whatever
and I'm sitting chatting to our and em
she said you looked a bit he looked a
bit down I was like oh yeah um had a
death in the family and asked feel a bit
aside feeling a bit sad and she was like
oh but don't you worry about a thing
I've got some good news for you I went
or what site and I'm really starting to
worry I'm like you know maybe she's just
kind of say we've got cake in the fridge
okay sure maybe she's gonna say I've got
a knife for young she goes you can join
him
Armageddon is coming brilliant I
instantly regret coming in for this I'm
looking at the cup of cup of coffee I'm
like what of you how quickly can I drink
yeah so did you drink the tea because it
happened I'm sipping it and I'm like
what what what's arm again she goes on
to tell me she is also religious
brilliant jehovah's witness brilliant um
the ones who like the knock at the doors
and tell you have you heard the truth I
mean have you heard the truth right well
I've now since learned that basically
the story goes you know we're all going
to be resurrected if you've died we're
going to be you know live in God's image
live off the land you know carrots and
turnip and whatever else he was really
good I could go for that especially you
loved spending time in London's do me
[__] headed I mean get rid of this
traffic for a start would be a godsend
yeah so anyway I saw the living in God's
kingdom would reduce the traffic I saw
my fists what they don't believe they
don't celebrate Christmas they don't
celebrate birthdays I think they're cuz
they're pagan is a pagan anyway not
right now only buzz it so they don't
celebrate any of that
don't celebrate but yeah that's sort of
her beliefs or in her mind any dead
people you know that come about the life
and she's helping you out ascend from
her perspective
she's like to me the good news yeah this
is great don't worry about your dead
relatives I'll be back in a few days or
whatever it is right so she's praying
that rotting relative go around yeah
God's gonna come out of the sky any
minute now and go you know I'm here for
back I bring them bring them all back
and you know I'm sick of all you waste
that's who I here get rid of you lot so
she's what happens those people to who
because as much as it's nice that your
family are coming back where are you
going me um into fire I sense you get
judged by God on the basis of if you've
got a good heart of something like that
I'm really having that Instagram meme
isn't it struggle record a lot of this
for any of you so not to worry people
have died I come back my life great as
it happens got that I maintain a good
relationship with that from that point
onwards because I don't want
you worried because she's a little lady
living on so I kind of said well you
know if you have here any weird noises
are you see any strange characters or
anyone says it just give us a ring I'll
come down and you know I'll make sure
everything's all right
yeah well yeah better than your new bar
apparently so flat me um yeah I'm
trapped in the same unlocked essentially
at night in the same room as those in
the same house as this year not the same
room that really would be weird what
we're doing here you and according to me
here
we sound mates just chained to a
radiator anyway um so a few months go by
remember death not a problem
yeah I'll come back the life phone call
she's she's there at the window every
day going he'll be back in a minute
don't worry about it anything any second
now and it really was every time I see
that after that it was a bit like I'm
against still not yeah and what kind of
weather were havin though anyway so I
got a phone call a few months in living
there she rings up and I'm like yeah
like a like Blair Witch vibe on the
other than the for New Zealand
Brian who know me mum's died well
nevermind Armageddon's coming yeah she
didn't seem to have a ticker own advice
for when she got the water hypocrite the
good Lords message when social us hits
people huh yeah funny old thing uh the
first thing I thought was bloody hell
your mother still alive I mean she was
about sixty I mother must have been
knocking on ninety mmm anyway
reasonable a she died I just said III
I'm on me way down after anyways she's
she's a Wright State Fair first thing I
do is I grab her a strong drink away and
I say yeah you're gonna need this you
know calm down many of you have a wine
you say yeah the body and blood of
Christ um so anyway I'm talking to her
and thought I know what I'll do I just
got a nearby close by I'll go and grab
our neighbor but before they do that she
started like curse and Jehovah Jehovah
be and God
and she's like Jehovah you're letting me
down oh my what do you done yeah told
you you're gonna have to get me a me
mother through Armageddon and me dogs
Britain wonder dogs two dogs two girls
so she was dogs or two girls two [__]
to pitcher so I was like
ooh this is so just before I bout leave
the door are you consistently remind you
at this point don't worry Armageddon
will be here soon you said it yourself
you'll all be dead soon I was just like
oh it's all right you know I'm just
saying anything at the take your own
advice mate yeah it's funny how they
don't really seem to believe it that
much one happens anyway and saying
terrible ass so just perfectly the
doctor can get her friend who's in the
equal age and similar life experience of
you or hear her friend like she started
punching herself in at the face both
fists gorgeous and just really beaten
the [__] piss out of us are darling
Jesus Christ so I have to run all that
one grubber by the wrists and I'm like
it upsets me when you hit yourself
yeah please don't hit yourself anyway I
make I make a beeline for the door I'm
straight out with a grabber me and I
opened the door I made and I'm like oh
like you know just just about what she
called she saw which was called Celia
and I me it was called cared about locks
I'm a core member
anyway Celia anyway I'm it was a right
[__] I was inning let's call a Cruella
a semi-wet she was a real [__]
so anyway open the door and she goes am
i said are Celia as mother's die jiggles
not again oh no she'll be drinking and
hitting myself than is she she always
does that I thought well me once told me
meet what to be fair you could have told
as I was making friends with an actual
cycle I'm going to be fair to her
Cruella
good judge of character yeah nailed it
yeah Neil did you go nailed it brilliant
she was me coming over on our knees it's
gonna be a good laughter so which is
packing for Armageddon Simon this
assignment cull of friends that one so
I'll bring our over yeah yeah you're not
going to boot camp she walks over she
walks up through the door the first
words out of her mouth this is how
unpatriotic was so she's popped it then
has she brilliant right first weirdo mm
she's it's sobbing a heart I would sit
at this point and I go ah probably not
the best choice of words and she goes I
don't worry about it man
you know as you don't you know that they
all go to heaven anyway and I'm like mmm
see that's that's not their beliefs
though that's actually there is not
nothing until Armageddon saw my
you wait in a while for heaven yeah then
I never as RM as the sort of trying to
talk they're trying to talk I look on
the floor the two lesbian dogs strangely
aroused by the whole thing and now start
humping each other what do you what are
they doing they're just like really from
in each other strap on what's going to
do I was what are they getting I've
never seen lesbian [__] quarter
before and I and I it's not the dog for
I know what's unusual that the fact that
you say lesbian humping dogs makes me
question the whole story that's the only
thing that made me question the story
it's totally true me I swear to God I
swear down on my life this is true right
so I'm I'm trying to feed the dogs but
they probably haven't been fed and
[__] dude you're right if people [__]
all they want is to be fed mm-hmm I
thought they'd want that for afters so I
put the food down and I laugh at me I
just I turn row and you I turn round and
Cruella's talking to Sarah and she's
like she's alright in that she goes what
what what's the date and I went out 20th
of October as it happens and she went
2010 Oh No
2010 23 jehovah you've let me down
that's exactly she was saying hey what's
wrong man trend it's me mom's bestie I
mean she's died on our birthday and our
miracle - calendar I mean our vehicles
yeah but you don't celebrate birthdays
here's a good point as a very good point
that goes but I do yeah and it's my
grandson's today hey hey wait so I was
like that's my cue to leave and I never
went back after that really just all
right distance meself now this is right
this is the end so that was my
experience I so love you stranger I mean
I don't know who's weird weirder Celia
or karela because what religious in some
wishing before ways mm-hmm
both but both of us one I never actually
hit me she just hit ourselves so I would
take a self Harmer over that any dude
but it does upset you when she hit
herself
I didn't want the way you wish in some
way watching an old lady hit us off is a
real strange thing yeah
trust yeah okay I have some really meaty
problems this week
would you like to study a let's start
with this one this one's a good one
hey BB that's you big Brian yeah you're
a [__] lad just state the [__]
obvious this is my story
we were highschool sweet just go
straight into it no no foreplay just
straight into that we were school
sweethearts that go to different
colleges she came to visit me last
weekend forgot to log out of Facebook on
my computer before she left
imagine that hours he spent looking at
every single [__] detail in that
message the next line is is summarized
it perfectly I accidentally in italics
stumbled upon her inbox and found
messages from a boy from her school the
message is included when are we going to
break or when are you going to break up
from him oh and that rim job last night
was so good Norway
yeah ensued yeah it says with three
exclamation marks and there was a fair
amount of sexting - she's been eatin s
in case anyone's wondering my favorite
line from her down tongue punching the
fart box I'll never forget is is your
come thick baby
Oh [__] really weird Howie yeah
um who the [__] asked that he says I
still I'm still with this girl and I
don't know what to do do I threaten the
boy to beat the [__] out of the [__] or
do I carry on as normal as she um she
gives me good sex as well obviously
what's your advice she's eaten mein oh
yeah that one of em Japanese women who
ask generally they are the filthiest of
the filthy right so she's probably your
experience fantastic in bed right she'd
I mean usually so Fair Play I titled
this one Facebook cheat by the wall she
reciprocated the messages sound there
was sexting and she said gone I mean to
be fair when she's sending the text is
you're come thick baby I think is a
reciprocal relationship or sort of a
medical thing so shows he sort of
contouring on Jesus Christ I I think I'm
my [__] is too thick he's egon is you'll
come thick core he's not like I took
that as if she tasted it and it was like
like McDonald's milkshake yeah I mean
why she asking if she knows right okay I
mean the good thing then is that means
she hasn't seen that come so I just
think in general anytime you cut your
lusts sending dirty messages to another
blow [__] Connor straight straight load
stop in her own goodbye that is
basically she I'm trying on facebook she
are just a lot me as far as I'm saying
she she's about to cheat if she hasn't
already
hey I think emotionally she's already
gone she's already gone yeah physically
it's about I mean that rim job last
night was so good would indicate she's
probably already cheated I mean either
that re speaking about someone else
getting uncommon and bragging I wouldn't
even send that you do you know I mean I
think it's not a it's not a conversation
starter is it in orders yeah you vote
rim job last night was so good come on
she's being eaten Harry monos I mean it
might be waxed you don't know that my
advice would be true hey don't stay in a
relationship with her B do not blame the
man because he doesn't know you've madam
love any solid toss that the other day
is not hurting anyone err in a
roundabout way yes um I just get rid of
her you go in separate schools your
offer your own college just live life
she tossed her solid yeah let it go and
he let her tosses oh and good advice
difficult I what I'm trying to put my
heart into these problems a lot more
when I hear things like that I really
connect hmm I've got a good one here um
okay here we go
first off love the podcast thanks Cheers
what you want to name this game mmm Adam
Adam good where'd you get that one that
just helped him and it was his second
thing Adam mechanic mmm Adam bolt would
bolt okay hey Adam uh it says here
podcast is great it's [__] great keep
up the work you sick [__]
so as a compliment in Australia so my
problem is I have decision to make to
this point I've been holding on to my
virginity for someone who I really care
about but I'm having doubts on the point
of that philosophy the point being is
keeping his virginity and there's a girl
I've been with a couple of times did
oral and hand stuff
and they're like and she made it clear
she wants to have sex
I imagined through saying I wanna have
sex she's not exactly virtuous though
Wow he's caught despite the fact he's
received it oral and a [__] off this
girl he's calling her into question
she's not exactly virtuous though to put
it nicely she's a bit of a ho to be
honest he says he says not my words I'm
just wondering if I say [__] it and well
[__] it or do I just keep this ideal
that I have if right in an ideal world
in my opinion you're gonna lose your
virginity to a good girl
yeah a good girl that maybe that's a
high expectation someone you love I
don't know but a good girl who isn't a
hole right but some aims beggars can't
be choosers rightly not beggar and he's
got an ideal and anonymous it is either
because of his getting hand jobs off
[__] and oral and oral orals vet a
very intimate thing to do I mean or to
receive and give oral sex I know that
it's sort of crotch baiting on face to
face but it is I think given oral is a
lot more intimate than receiving because
receiving I mean I'm not as picky but
given I'm very picky chin and I mean
well yeah both ways but no no no no like
I will only eat the [__] of a girl I
think is like amazing and like she has
to be what Queen Jennah mean whereas you
let anyone not anyone yeah I wouldn't go
that far
cheers me yeah but exceptions will be
made right just sin yeah but if I'm
going down there she better be stipulate
that 10 out of 10 what I'm saying is do
you think he goes that what rock roots
to go here does he because it must be
very difficult for him it this way to
sort of pull himself away and so we go
okay we've done hand job if he's home as
much just get off [__] will you just
like yo he values his virginity
obviously not me if he's given it up the
Mia fight if he happens
[__] yes a really good point actually do
you think do you think he's already lost
it though because of the oral and their
virginity is you know penetration pop
knob in person I don't know if that's
true I think I think or all sort of
counts you've sort of been inside so
it's sort of it's you're half way there
woah livin on a prayer great voice not
very from East End not quite right
so what you saying is he got a jug mitt
good Lud Silla brilliant my advice would
be stay virtuous go to chug keep that
ring on go to choke imagine he's got
that chastity ring I want someone whose
life is in [__] tatters
okay so I've good one here I finally
moved on from this girl that I liked oh
good
and I have to say I'm a lot happier good
for you whenever I saw inspirational
[__] on the Internet it never helped
to move on and I had to find my own way
you're right because normally when I say
inspirational [__] on the internet I
think god that's really helped me
normally I'm feeling really down and
then I see an Instagram meme and I'm
like actually I feel much better yeah
you're right yeah great nice actually
all right thanks Instagram anyway since
moving on I haven't found slash met
anyone who has hit me in the same way as
the previous kill I've not lost my
virginity and that's something I'm
hoping to do within the next year all
set goals but I can't seem to feel the
same about anyone I've met do I go
through Geordie route or the Lawrence
route when it comes to finding a girl do
I go and get a girl that's a bit met and
see if it turns out or do I stick around
and look for this special one thanks you
[__] I've got the answer don't do one
of the other do both right so he has my
own sasebo yeah as my motherís they're
nice you can do will mix and match all
right so Lawrence is of the belief of
hold out for the great one pretty much
should have a really lovely person right
I'm of the belief mmm you know is that
really going to happen so a bit more
realistic in life how about the
realistic combine them no how about you
combine the two I'm saying yeah my
thoughts are that they're not mutually
exclusive II can do boss may and you you
do both those styles you don't just hold
out for the great one don't just go out
and you know bang whatever moves in your
younger years how about you both yeah
bang whatever moves for a while and then
if you meet a great one then settle down
right because the one thing I will admit
I've been a bit harsh lately I've liked
the podcasting am I giving up the best
advice no not always
you sound like a terrible business a
connection with a girl when you meet the
right one and there's a bit of
electricity in the change you
I [__] win I'm gonna rub this in your
[__] face but let's go for dinner
after this now a little chat about why
your perspective change no double right
condom
I'm just saying and if you meet someone
that you click with that is more special
I'm willing to admit then you know the
regular they make a class with him all
right me so anyway how about DuBose
entertain your son in the meantime
you've got to get good at sex before the
good one comes along as well me because
you don't want her turning up and you
still being crap in bed she might be the
one that teeth on your skills with the
the buggers and then when you find a
good one you'll impress her that's
really not the approach that I would say
take but I would say we've compromised
on this menu no no you've compromised
and assume I'm coming all right what I
would say is if she it first of all you
don't need to get practice before you
get into your first relationship you
know if you're if you're in a good
relationship then that person will say
with your experience or not I want to be
with you and I you know I'll either help
you develop sexually so go on that route
or if they don't then screw it don't no
no no you want to build that could have
put a knock it out the park
first open over month yeah but you know
that that's not realistic because every
Ellie's it is oh you mean I thought
sorry I thought you meant for virgin
virgin some of other girls it is thought
it can have no problem yeah but you
don't want to see other human beings as
and let me put this way practice all
right yes red and corns on Apple I just
run around so I look like I did finish
in 1 minute 30 there but that's a
personal best and so it doesn't work
that way people can't be practice
because emotionally you're leading them
on you're going yeah call it sex I'll
get intimate I know you can be honest as
long as you be honest with the girls
that you are not even attractive and not
you're just saying I'm not looking for
anything serious you know
so I'm as you're honest from the day
like and you be honest and say I will
never look at you that way this is just
fun yeah never say never say in that
tongue though all right maybe not maybe
bit nice answer
we're friends with benefits get that
sort of thing going on before we start
here I just want you to know I will
never look at you in that way anyways it
RF and I put my penis inside you before
I just wanna let you know you are a five
out of ten don't even think that this is
gonna last just one let you know you are
nothing to me let's commence dawn I just
want you to let you know you are just a
hole that's all you are that is all
that's who haribol you are nothing more
than a cup of tea that I'm going to dunk
my hobnob just gonna and eat it let's
just say this now if the girl then
agrees have sex with you after you said
that to her face don't do not commence
she's on girls solid girls no but some
girls will are literally just happy and
grateful for anything that comes along
it's Jesus this is awful
no they are some people though like some
guys are metal to me yeah some men and
women I'm not being discriminate you can
also be a good person at that point and
go
look there's clearly something wrong
here Angela let's not go down that route
let's let's not have sex tonight not
what you do here's what you do right I
agree that you have to build a people up
in general you want to make them feel
better about themselves to think but
first wait until you're done with them
ask oh oh I think sometimes you say
things I react and then and then go I'll
pretend that was a joke oh you're good
I'm joy joy oh yes oh all right all
right of course if you're feeling
reasonable you're feeling good you don't
want to do that but they I've got to be
honest at times I've taken advantage of
women and I probably shouldn't have done
mm-hmm but you know we live in Yellen
that's all I'm soon but it is you Lenny
alone yeah put it this way you did not
lie to get a hotel room key card and you
didn't escape out the fire escape so
you're still a good man mmm you know
what I mean I don't know who you
reference and all that move the [__] on
all right let's finish on a very sweet
problem I think I've chosen a nice
problem that I think you can give some
good advice for this week this is a
meaty but ultimately nice at heart
problem ready mmm hi Jordy get bit load
on that muscular hi Jordy all right okay
I'm 15 and I want to ask a girl to go
out to prom with me
oh that's a good on it I don't know
which way to go about it funny creative
romantic etc is worrying us know what
you thinking it what do you think I
should do
he says I've known this girl for a
out eight years and once asked her out a
few years ago but she said no however
since then things have changed and I
think she likes me but I'm not sure and
I talked to her a lot of the time that's
where his email ends all right
well just because you said no a few
years ago doesn't mean things do change
a lot especially a 15 I mean he easy
you've had a long dating curing by this
point if you're 15 yeah I mean let's be
honest like see I saw it when he was 12
he's gonna look different now than when
he did when he was 12 I'd say so have
some faith have some self belief don't
be corny with it and like some surprise
I with creativity that worries me that
word creative and you know it's like
it's gonna burst out of her you know I
think I don't know maybe her mother's
buta something after they've driven home
from school and he's gonna be there
going surprise and then I even mother's
going I don't know how he got in
mayonnaise yeah they're cops
let's just let's go up to her after
school lunches on our own and just say
look I really like you
yeah happy and thinking about the dance
that's coming up and out there's nobody
I'd rather go with and watching you from
a distance there's no one I'd rather go
with yet than you guys a lovely line
probably yeah and if she breaks your
little heart and she says no yeah see
she got some practice no I took it like
a man and just say all right no bar
don't show any [__] emotion at all
and just walk away your right is livid
at that we need to encourage modern men
not to show any emotion not because
that's not a problem in love me you
don't want to be like a little [__]
though I'm [__] crying and all that
[__] does he don't show any emotion me I
don't care if it's this modern wheel
2006 it I'm from Clint Eastwood's around
my head mate you don't you look at our
squinty eyed and you walk away right
yeah but don't ask her out squinty items
you know go over and go and then
watching you I got a cell phone question
do you want to go to prom with me do you
feel lucky the question is do you feel
Brown with me and she's like a Alexson
he's like oh yeah this is a god right
these fifty and he won't even know the
[__] in these waters anyway cool see
well you guys chatted the Oh empty chair
now the point is just give it your best
and if it doesn't work you'll not be the
first man who's heard the word no
believe me just make sure you pay
attention to what you do
signal and take no for an answer yes
always when someone says no say no never
go yeah that's it I would say so yeah
take it like a man and just prepare for
an or before you go up but just say all
right you may turn all here I'm gonna
but positive vibes voice not like I'm
sure to go okay prepare for the no and I
mean do you want to go to prom with me
no but I think a lot of the time it's
like it's like going into a fight
psychological and sometimes you can be
beaten before you even throw the first
punch and I think if she's doing that
don't ask her to prom don't definitely
don't throw a punch but the point is
just have a bit of self belief in
yourself but it what's the worst that's
gonna happen she says no it's not the
end of the the thing is too many people
in this world are frightened of what
people think of them like don't be like
that you aren't let it go I don't give a
[__] I think everyone knows and that's
very clear but you let you gotta let
that go because one of the most powerful
things you can achieve especially as a
young person is getting to call the prom
with you 15 to 25 is that moment where
you realize well I am Who I am
and I don't give a [__] what anyone
thinks that is the best part from you
and I want to spend all my time with you
I love you please get to prom with me
yeah yeah like I didn't get that in into
Twitter mm-hmm
us and a lot of them you know any weird
stuff you want to talk about any
anything at all that snow
one lad tweeted us in broke up after 15
years we partner I've spent half my life
with her how do I start dating again any
any words from Lawrence's I usually
answer these but I want to hear your
response to my Twitter a lot must be
hard after 15 years to break up with
someone like your basically you've
become a whole different person with
them you're actually you're almost like
a joined person at that point like you
do everything together I guess and you
evil said Davis your opinions your
influence there's probably at that point
you can't even go to make a cup of
coffee without thinking are after me too
because those she likes at this window
yeah so and you that's fine you know do
that that's alright you'll miss that
initially that's not the advice you want
how do you want to get back into dating
you want to say man up you want to get
out the big lower hull boat watch I
would say watch some romantic films for
a start so go on tell me
alright I'll tell you what I've just
lost me [__] misses I tell you I'm
gonna watch everyone be happy I know
I'll watch pretty [__] woman in the
lake no no like hitch like things where
single men in the end get the girl
alright so heat so it's like oh you're
trying to get back into the scene okay
I'll take some advice it Wow he wears a
blue shirt on the first day okay a calm
color to calm her down cut well you you
read into things way more than a calm
color the calm eye down
how about it's just a nice [__] [__]
it's not a calm color yeah what are you
it says you like a body language sort of
person nobody I'm totally about you what
if someone's doing this right they want
it right so what am i what am i what I'm
wearing now put note like what vibe am i
giving off high key sort of now you
given out a vibe that you rinse us let's
put it this way they're not their own
race put it this way um you 100% you
definitely don't come from London the
world yeah um yeah dog [__] for that
yeah I've given the faux buff yeah
because when I get called freshy all the
time
my girlfriend calls me fresh what does
that mean it means so I get called like
tongue Frances fellows so in a way
because I am quite like when I first
came to London it was it so if you walk
down the streets of London you can so
clearly go not London London not London
London London London London even like 20
minutes outside you're still no mmm okay
so I'm giving off that not London vote
anyway that's not great advice for him
if you wanna get back into it
look what some romantic films definitely
don't go to those people who do that
dating advice stuff you know the guys
who do like the one among hey I'm Brad
number one and one consultant I can get
you a woman in the first three weeks
like no that sounds like something I'd
love to do for a job
yeah I think you'd be great at that and
we sort that oh it's good its sinister
as help I know how all women think
there's 15 things and every woman wants
and I'm gonna show you all I would say
one thing that every woman wants yeah a
good relationship are everything good
that is what every woman wants
everything and I'm fine with that
if someone wants commitment then go for
it no maybe he's not looking for
commitment how about we just go get it
get him in there at the deep end get
internet dating me tinder
get them buck talking to women and
embrace the fact that you
have had to show one woman for 15 years
and that's now law no longer a problem
you know what they're enjoy variety
again me you've been regulated a chicken
and rice for 15 14 years and now there's
burritos the sausage
there's pizza there's Indian there's all
sorts of good stuff he's in sample but
what if he's intolerant to dairy nobody
I mean the things that some things
aren't super from but the bottom line is
me bloody hell
you look a bastard enjoy your soul but a
better way to look at it would be also
maybe he wants to be vegan mmm who wants
to be V alright so okay got internet it
and I think that that's good right let's
move on looking at some some other
questions we've got from people just
before we end yeah favorite kind of porn
any preferences I'll be honest I don't
watch porn I don't really get annoyed
when men told me that because I do it
you liar
no no not at all I actually believe you
I think cuz you're so satisfied with
your sex life right me
I don't need porn any patents meanwhile
me every day
grunting await me do you search do you
and you out do you have set websites
that you go I go on one website more
than the others in that one that verge
is talking about I'm not going to
promote because I you know what I could
do with the sponsorship why'd you go on
that website a website one do why'd you
go on that way I just think bit of
variety in it but if you like the layout
to like the aesthetic I like being able
to just I when I go on I like random to
start over just cuz I'll it soup what's
going on bill run but come on there's
gotta be think like sure you've end up
on time running things you like that is
oh of course but you go khaki is
discussed you've got to take the good
with the bad in porn it's like anything
in life isn't it really sometimes you're
gonna come up with cross when we go who
is our porn so I never see another so
you saying you've tried it email this
doesn't make a mental note of that girl
because I'm gonna want to search for her
in future do you ever have you ever
tried to get off to something that you
were originally thought this is
discussing he thought it's a bit like
you know with food way like I don't
really like mushrooms but I think the
one thing that was porn I've noticed as
I've got older is see when I first
started looking a porn when I was I
don't know [__] 14 whatever was
alternate engine I anything even just a
regular woman who was
not even that attractive just naked but
now but now like uh it is a bit like
drugs in booj compared drugs a lot when
we talk it's like you have to get more
and more not it's not always the case
but I found myself looking at things up
five 10 years where I would never have
looked at because I'm just like [__]
hell I am is shocked a bit more do you
ever feel guilty I never feel guilty I
mean for yourself to ever sort of think
oh god I shouldn't be I should not have
looked at that no no I never feel like
that you know shut the laptop and guys
that was I feel terror the ones I prefer
prefer looking up generally or like
realistic sort of sentence or like a
girl on a webcam shoving a dildo abba
are quite late watching the hell you
like yeah does it worry you know do you
ever do you ever think do you ever think
hey there's hundreds of other men on
this exact same website with their [__]
out whacking away at the same time as me
are that right now just as we're just as
we're recording this there are hundreds
of some around this link over this right
now taking a big ol [__] mmm wiping is a
stick and the biggest meanest [__]
you've ever seen in your entire life
reality is as it does I don't know what
you mean by now that's it that's it oh
you're saying is you have thought of
other men masturbating whilst you were
definitely not definitely not but it's a
sad thing to know that people are doing
disgusting things around the world at
all times as what I'm saying is it
disgusting masturbation are having a
[__] blinder do you think I both
discussed bodily functions I suppose
let's move on must measure now on the
last one yes question any moments where
either of us have thought what the [__]
am I doing with my life every morning
when I wake up every morning when you
wake up and that American Muslim sitting
next year the matter is a Muslim that's
not calling that let's just call him an
American all right Lilly release music
and his pots and I'm not joking get up
I'm not joking so um eat this this came
to a head the other night well we've
gone over that when I went to the toilet
at 5 a.m. and I went so I going to the
toilet right and I I look in the in the
bowl and it's yellow Oh
and I was like okay that's fine you know
what at night sometimes people flush the
toilet it wakes me up so I think is
worried about that I think but I think
that's perfectly reasonable all right I
won't flush the toilet either so a pee
and then I leave the toilet wash my
hands and then go back in to us we
didn't flush no because I was like you
know we all pee and his pee when I
renewed now wait now this is the funny
bit right like loud hard 5:00 5:00 a.m.
Burma 5:00 a.m. I get up I'm like okay
great let's go brace myself take the
iPhone off charge it record before you
and I go out turn the lights on whether
you've got another you got another
postmates as well yeah but I don't know
those those people are involved with it
there's nothing they're not there like I
don't know cuckoo so he goes what is
this and I was like it's 5:00 a.m. and
like what like I'm serious it's like
you've done this before and I was like
what have I done before and he goes did
you just take it just go to the toilet
and I was like maybe and he was like did
you and I was like no and he's like but
the toilet is yellow why and I was like
Perry summers pea peanut is on hygienic
don't flush it PM listen pee I'm
guessing some piss on hygienic you've
done it before I was like even if I had
it wouldn't matter and he was like flush
it and I was like again they were the
piss and the toilet of knowledge yeah
and I I that point I went question what
you're doing me because if you like
that's the one place it belongs all
right that's well would you rather it me
yeah would you rather I went in into the
kitchen was like I'll just take a leak
in here was he's watching looking you
know why I wanna clock but I'll be like
I'm pissing in the faster it came around
I could see that what would piss him off
more than peeing in the sink so anyway
he shouts he goes flush the toilet and I
was like stop lying to the police and he
was like flush the toilet and I was like
stop lying to the police and this went
on before he went in hid in the kitchen
because he got so angry and he just kept
shouting through the door
flush the toilet or this will become
unlivable
and I'm standing there no no I mean oh
he's being like I don't understand I
just don't know I don't know what's
going on this is his name what the focus
is unlivable Oh God I kind of the moment
that isn't this is so weird though isn't
it anyway I go in the toilet flush the
toilet and was just like there you go
and so now every time that he's in the
house and I go to the toilet I'll make
sure that he now knows that I flushed
the toilet
I just got just flush the toilet for you
there and then go I think I think what
that tweet was getting that was like not
this I'm lacking direction yeah in life
I think everyone has moment especially
in the early twenties our late teens
we're asked to make decisions that are
just gonna affect before the rest of our
life and my like I don't know if this is
the [__] right thing for me I don't
know I want to [__] be doing our if I
don't know what I want to be doing this
isn't it and I'm losing direction
sometimes do get that feeling yeah um if
I follow that absolutely when I when I
left University sort of at the I was in
a job but I was sort of like running in
the business what am i doing am I ever
gonna be able to like make videos that I
want you feel you get to a point you
sort of feel like what am i doing what
is my purpose in the business in life
you know do other people like me all
these sort of things you go through all
those questions even if you're a very
confident person you'll still ask those
things because you have to assess and I
really like what Steve Jobs says to all
the graduates he says you can only join
the dots backwards but when you're going
forwards go out there with intent and be
humble about what you do and I think
that's fair enough
I'm not I'm not sort of preaching at
anyone but I think you you know it's not
you can look forward to go I want to go
there there there and then because you
never go exactly that route you'll
always be another route to where you
want to go I was thinking about this the
other day actually because of something
to chat with a pretty young thing
good-looking girl you know yeah they
were sayin to me you know feeling like a
bit like and direction and that and I
think sometimes you don't realize when
you're at that age that the things
you're doing or you are connecting dots
towards where you want to be eventually
but it just doesn't seem like it now so
like with me
I actually found diving on a YouTube
video really i ice
scene diving on a YouTube video I
thought I could do that I want to do
that and it looks great looking down I
got it I wonder how many views that
video got I got into diving through
watching YouTube and then I knew that
was could you actually have a finite I
have that because I know I know the
video like really well I watch it a
million times and at the time in diving
like I felt a bit lost some names like
what the [__] what the [__] am I doing
with me life but now like for example
when we were on the sidemen livestream
we had like half a million people
watching us live a lot of people would
[__] freak out if they knew half a
million people and watching them at that
moment I know I did
but to me even though those jobs are so
not linked like because I've been in
life or death situations on a regular
basis it mean in my job now talking in
front half of many people's oh I'm not
going to die yeah you know so it might
not seem like what you're doing is going
to connect to the future but you may
actually yeah that was sort of one of my
what-the-fuck moments when I was waking
up on a boat somewhere thinking where
the [__] I'm at is this what I really
want to be doing but just trust the
process and don't I guess there's a
point where you know you kind of you
feel a bit like bit dazed it's kind of
like you don't know quite where you're
going
talk to people about it sometimes just
give it the time to be able to pose I
think people are expected to pick the
careers far too it may feel like they're
expected because I was told out when I
was I was really good at economics in
school and so I was like I want to go do
economics we didn't do we can homage to
my school and then if I didn't I
actually add to go to another school to
be able to do it so it wasn't the
immersion school anyway the point is
that I ended up not doing that I ended
up sorry it out of money
sorry not part of our economy and so I
went the other way and went intermediate
and actually you know it was there are
certain people know certain turning
points but you can only look at those
when you're looking back when so one of
my dad's best friends took me out for a
drink
we were all out for drink can you just
turn to me about don't do economics
economics is one of the most boring
things that you will do as interested as
you are in economics he said to me
you're not an economics guy you're
someone who should be like showing
people what you cannot see is like a
media thing but go and do that he said
not one day you'll be paying the person
who
studied economics to work for you but
only if you do something well yeah and
me being stuck on a board for 12 I was a
foot indie or whatever the [__] it was
at each day I had nothing to do other
than think of new ways to take the piss
and now that helps me to think of new
ways to take the piss on videos that I
is true and you know what that there is
also there's a I know that everyone's
got these stories we've all been through
a journey life don't think that just
because you hear like one or two stories
you know you're boring or that your
friends are boring or that anyone's
where everyone's got a story like
everyone has been through that boring
moment that terrible moment really good
really good highs those really bad lows
there's an you know there's no one out
there is living a perfect life the point
is when you are in that very boring
moment it can sometimes help you to know
that there is also something really good
coming so like you know when you first
graduate you get a terrible shitty job
or ever is actually alright and you are
either way life's probably gonna get
better from there on that note life is
gonna get better next week for everyone
yeah next week got a guest coming on
next week make sure you stay tuned for
that if you've enjoyed this a really
excited I'm really excited because
there's gonna be some good stories all
the lessons on that so make sure you hit
the like button if you enjoyed this on
YouTube stay subscribe to the true Jody
YouTube channel subscribe to this on
iTunes thanks for watching and we will
see ya